dernier jour pour la semaine créole à
salazie dans la salle des fêtes delbourg
un public contenu a pu découvrir les
artisans qui font de la tradition créole
un patrimoine vivant une ambiance relevé
par deux musiciens patrick manoro et
faro
[Musique]
minet saibene mhamid el maleh
salazie étant le berceau du marronnage à
la réunion le public a pu savourer
l'histoire d'anchin premier marron dont
une montagne du cirque porte le nom une
histoire évoqué par hermine a pas dhr
une élue conteuse et féru de sirandane
ces énigmes en créole couronne simon
tête et condamnent monkey - même le roi
seulement voilà pas le roi le roi de la
basse cour
oui mais seulement 10 les peindre parmi
les exposants des représentants du
savoir faire traditionnel très sage de
chapeau en paille chouchou et
fabrication d'ustensiles en fer blanc
c'est marlène techer de l'association el
diablo qui a sélectionné les
participants la pro photo de tous les
gens que les labels mérite d'être là
parce que c'est notre culture c'est
assez nouveau
c'est ça l'a dit c'est un rayon autour
des stands des tableaux tout en relief
attire l'attention des scènes de vie
d'antan mariage paysage ce sont les
oeuvres de louis jessu l'un des
pionniers du théâtre à la réunion un
parolier auteur de comédies musicales
religieuses alice grondin fait tout son
possible pour honorer sa mémoire au sein
d'une association
la première pièce qui est passé sur une
télévision
ça a été les pèlerins de saint louis il
ya au moins 52 pièces en créole notre
association est dans sa maison et nous
faisons vivre
louis jessu en faisant du théâtre de la
peinture on verrait un atelier peinture
justement l'atelier c'est avec betsy
grondin peintre à la retraite qui
enseignent comment dessiner la forêt de
bélouve c'est facile c'est facile si on
a un bon enseignement si on écoute
vraiment si on est attentif à ce qu'on
fait oui et en ces temps difficiles de
restrictions tous les acteurs du
patrimoine le savent on ne sauvegardent
la tradition quand la partageant
[Musique]